i feel like people have been waiting to
hear your side of this story for a long
time
finally it's coming why now and why
in seduce for a long time i would i just
wasn't ready to speak out
i needed to take care of myself and
prioritize my own healing and recovery
and i was kind of turned off by the
media to be honest i was thinking
okay cult girl sex slave all these sort
of
terrible tag lines are being attached to
me like why would i want to talk to you
i really just took the time away and
when all of that was happening i
actually got introduced to the producers
and the directors on seduced
and they explained to me that they had a
vision for a very different type of
documentary that was female focused
created by a female team of filmmakers
and that it was going to go deep into
coercion and high control groups and i
thought
oh that is something that i can get
behind i grew up looking for a more
purposeful life
nexium was a program to make people's
lives better i found real deep sense of
community i felt like i was in the right
place
so how did we all end up in the clutches
of a monster well i think you delivered
on
the vision there because i feel like so
many times any sort of occult
documentary comes out people are like i
would never be in a cult how could
somebody get into this
seduced lays out exactly how
you were manipulated into falling down
this rabbit hole that was my
goal i just wanted it to be real it
really reinvigorated my
belief in myself and what i could do in
my future where
for a long time i didn't really see
anything besides albany from my life
what was the hardest part of making this
series
definitely going back into those
memories and then having to go
revisit those places and be there
that was really hard my body was
freaking out
i started having panic attacks my throat
felt like it was closing i had acid
reflux just on the freaking train
from penn station and i thought okay
clearly there's some unfinished business
here
i had to ask permission to eat there's
control of sleep demeaning
sexual acts it kept getting more extreme
all over the globe
we don't know how many victims there
could be the cruelty
it's beyond the pale i didn't want to be
saved
was anything off limits was there
anything that you said i will not go to
this place
no actually no i'd already had this
story sort of told
for me if you will and i wanted to
change that
this is coming out after the vowel which
is also telling your story without you
there's no good way to leave ever
as much as she doesn't know how to let
go of this cult i've not let
i go to expose what's going on this has
to be stopped
how do you feel about the vow have you
watched any of it
i haven't watched any of it it's really
hard for me to watch
a lot of that footage i wanted to stay
focused on this project and
i also have a book that's coming out at
the same time
about all the red flags that i didn't
see that i wish i had
and for me i didn't participate it
in it for a number of reasons mostly
because i wasn't ready at the time
but i think anything that can bring
awareness to these topics is good
so to me it's not a competition it's
just
information i think yours so beautifully
informs missing pieces of the vow
you fill in so many gaps so many
questions that are left from the vowel
that i think people are going to walk
away from seduced
with the full 360 degree picture of what
it was like
to be in this organization minutes ago a
federal jury here in the eastern
district of new york
returned verdicts convicting keith
renery
on all counts in his federal indictment
keith renery's crime spree has
ended and his victims will finally
see justice keith ranieri was found
guilty on every charge brought against
him
he maintains his innocence his
sentencing is coming up though
what will be a satisfying sentence for
him
yeah i'm actually going to go and i'm
going to speak there
um i have a statement written
i just needed that closure and
i think for me life in prison is really
the only thing that i would feel
satisfied and safe with because i don't
think that he's somebody who
is capable of changing i mean he's
operating as a wannabe mob boss from
prison now
trying to control people to go on cbs on
his behalf like being used
and if he was released he would do the
same thing and he would hurt more people
i'm just not okay with that and that's
also why i wanted to speak
and i trust the judge i mean the judge
is wonderful and fair and
he is going to give him the sentence he
deserves but life in prison is what i
would want
to see the cbs this morning interview
the dancing outside of the prison
when you see that what goes through your
mind
a lot of feelings when i first saw the
dancing i thought it was a joke
i couldn't believe it i just thought how
do they not see that he gives two shots
about him and this is
basically for his own self gratification
to know that he can get people to dance
outside of a prison at 9 00 pm like
it was so absurd to me and i mean i get
really riled up about it because
it just shows you the power of
indoctrination and how dangerous it is
it's a real thing
seduced really explains how fixated
keith was on you
specifically did you ever get any
explanation or insight into why he was
so
narrowed in on you i don't like giving
keith that much credit
but if i will it will be that he was a
genius
at knowing how to manipulate and exploit
people for their specific
skills and i think one of the things
that i brought
to keith and to nexium was this positive
view of them i was told to be good and
look happy and i did
that was much more valuable than i could
have imagined for them
and on top of it he specifically placed
me with allison
in her apartment to make it look more
normal to make people feel more
comfortable because allison had a very
different personality than me she's very
intense very aggressive
more of a extrovert and i'm kind of
softer and more
gentle and i think people just generally
felt more comfortable with me than her
and that gave me the ability to
have people break down their walls and
come closer and closer to keith and
allison without me knowing what was
really happening
so i think there was a couple things at
play that i was unaware of
actress alison mack pleaded guilty to
racketeering charges today prosecutors
say she helped alleged nexium leader
keith renery get women into a secret
society in the group
she actually pleaded guilty to the
charge that was brought against her what
punishment would you
feel right for her alison is a broken
person and i consider her a victim of
keith renery and
not to say that she didn't hurt me or
other people because she did
and that's why she's facing those types
of charges
but broken people don't heal in prison
and i don't see her as somebody who's
going to get better as a result of
sitting in jail i think she's the type
of person that could
use tremendous amount of help and
therapy
and not my judgment to say how many
years she deserves
i just feel like she will get justice
will be served
you said in your book you'll lay out all
the red flags you missed along the way
that you've come to realize something
in watching seduce that i kept going
back to is why did no one
see allison giving up her big life her
successful career as a red flag they did
i lived with her for almost two years
and i remember her mom
and her family questioning her and she
had an explanation for everything and
keith said i should do this he said i
should do this was basically
the answer always and i think that was a
red flag to her mother
but she couldn't dispute it i mean she's
in her 30s she was living in new york
and what are you gonna do there were
also reasons why we stayed
obviously one being the collateral but
right
or the blackmail oh it's hard i mean
you can always kick yourself when you
look and retrace back like oh
why didn't i do this why didn't i see
that when you why didn't you say
anything
but when you're in it when you're in it
you don't see that it's hard do you have
a message
for keith or for alison today one of the
things that i
i said repeatedly to myself when when
things were really hard
was that this wouldn't break me and
i feel the same about them i mean yes it
was painful and it was cruel and it was
hard not only for me but for other
people but it didn't break me
like i still have my life and my spirit
and
yes i have hard days but
i'm not gonna let it take away the rest
of my life
that's a really positive place to come
from so that's really great
yeah i'm better now it's revealed in
seduce that
you were the person in nexium or esp who
went through the most ems which is kind
of the equivalent of
auditing in that organization did you
know that you were you had been the
person who went through the most
no i did not know that i even find that
statistic shocking now
no because ems were a constant thing i
had a lot of ems especially during the
time when my mother
was trying to extract me from nexium and
they were trying to keep me in mexium so
there was quite a bit of conflict and
stress and pressure
going on for me then you think that you
always have your mind
and you think that you always have your
own
will but the fact was that mine was
hijacked and it was taken from me
without me really knowing so having to
kind of
be slingshotted back into your new life
when you're still dealing with the
feelings of the past is difficult
and it's challenging and that i mean
em's included i have to still kind of
process
what was that like what happened and
sometimes it's not fun
your mom really fought to save you this
is my last resort going to the media
i'm only doing this to bring awareness
because without awareness there can be
no outrage
and unless there's outrage the
authorities are not going to step in and
do what they should do which is shut
this down
what would you say she did right that
parents who might be in a similar
situation
could learn from she fought like hell
and she didn't stop
i mean you're gonna make me cry but the
fact that she never gave up
was ultimately the thing that gave me my
life back i just
can't express how grateful i am to be
able to have the mom that i have
this organization would still be going
on if she hadn't exposed it in the media
in my opinion
and of course there was the work from
the government and the work from people
who left nexium
before i did that also helped to
dismantle this thing but
for other parents she just fought and
she kept fighting even when i couldn't
feel
it as love she kept going and even
though there were moments where
i thought we might never speak again
because of all the chaos and the
pressure that i was experiencing from
nexium
there was still that little part of me
that knew this was my mom
this was my mother who loved me and this
is
just some big misunderstanding that's
kind of like what i had to keep telling
myself
in order to be mentally okay with what
was going on
i think seduce does a much better job
too than the vow
of explaining how involved your mother
was in nexium
at the start did making this documentary
help heal some of the wounds that were
left between you and your mom
yeah it did it brought up a lot of stuff
that we hadn't addressed
a lot of things that maybe lay dormant
that you think you can move on with
but you can't that's one thing that i've
realized just for our own healing and
i'm looking after she's outside
but you just gotta lay it all out there
and know that the people
that love you love you and they won't
judge you
and there's no name to be had i mean
everyone has done stupid
everyone's made mistakes and we learned
from them and this just happened to be
something that i never anticipated
having to deal with and neither did my
mom
and we've grown a lot because of it and
i have so much respect for her
i love that you guys are together right
now yeah i came over to her house to do
all the interviews because i live in an
apartment with two cats
and a roommate and a fiance and it was
just chaos
and i tried to do one interview while my
fiance was making tea and i was
get out of here you're distracting me
while i'm trying to have this serious
conversation
but think about how rich your life is
right now that you have those
kind of mundane problems i i am telling
you
i could never have expected having the
life that i have now
never i mean i just feel so much
more me you say in the documentary
do i even know who i am did you get that
answer by the end of making seduced
yeah and a lot more i feel more myself
now than ever
and i feel like i said reinvigorated by
this whole experience like
actually seeing a future for myself so
yes
so so who is india oxenburg what
identifiers do you want to be known by
that aren't yeah
please take that off my resume but the
truth is that that is a part of my story
and those are experiences that i can't
just get rid of and i talk about that in
the documentary
i mean in order to heal you have to
accept it and go through it
and that's a daily process i mean
i'm still healing now and
i guess i'd like to say that i'm a
resilient and optimistic
person who wants to take advantage of
the time that was lost
and i am not going to take that for
granted
you